hey
[Applause]
Mike you want to do it now I had
allocated four different uniforms cuz I
knew if I wore one uniform and I tried
to keep that one uniform the Hall of
Fame wouldn't got nothing Jerry and I
would have been fighting over over the
same uniform so what I did was wore two
pair of pants that day first half and
the second half where's your helmet wore
four different jerseys first quarter
second quarter third quarter and fourth
quarter I changed socks at half time man
wore four different helmets four
different pairs of of shoes four
different pairs of gloves and two pair
of socks new gloves no I get you when
you come back on the field what they're
doing is they are heat sealing
microchips into all of the memorabilia
today so that nothing can be
fraudulently traded later on the first
quarter uniform I gave it to Jerry the
second quarter I sent to the Hall of
Fame the third quarter I kept for my own
charity and then when I broke the record
I kept for myself